la pandémie de kobe de 19 c'est l'une
des rares régions du monde
les contaminations repartent à la hausse
on y dénombre plus d'un million de morts
en cause une belle campagne vaccinale
encore trop lente résultats en argentine
le confinement option jusqu'au 30 mai
[Musique]
manifestation en soutien aux
palestiniens à paris mais aussi un peu
partout dans le monde alors que sur
place à gaza la situation revient peu à
peu à la normale après onze jours
d'affrontements entre le hamas et
l'armée israélienne
il est près de 250 morts cessez le feu
est finalement entré en vigueur le temps
est maintenant aller l'aide d'urgence et
à la reconstruction de l'enclavé
palestinienne
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france on commence
cette édition en france où la réforme de
l'assurance chômage ne passe pas à
l'appel de plusieurs syndicats ces
opposants se sont rassemblés cet après
midi à paris le cortège est parti du
théâtre de l'odéon direction le louvre
des syndicats mais aussi la coordination
des intermittents et précaires dénoncent
une réforme injuste
le mode de calcul du salaire journalier
de référence mesure phare de ce texte
est contestée il ya les organisations
syndicales ont déposé un recours devant
le conseil d'état pour obtenir sa
suspension
les juges ont un mois pour y répondre
notre reporter guimard aussi a suivi
cette manifestation à paris la
manifestation pour le retrait de la
réforme de l'assurance chômage est à
présent terminée c'est plus d'une
centaine de personnes qui a manifesté
entre le théâtre de l'odéon et le
conseil d'état où je me trouve
actuellement dans le cortège et bien il
y avait de nombreux salariés de
plusieurs secteurs de la culture des
intermittents certes bien entendu mais
pas seulement
les intermittents qui comme vous le
savez certainement ne sont pas
concernées au premier titre par cette
réforme de l'assurance chômage le calcul
de leurs indemnités diffère de celui des
salariés du régime général mais il avait
aussi dans le cortège des salariés qu'on
appelle précaire c'est qu'on appelle
également des salariés permet une paire
mi temps il s'agit des saisonniers il
s'agit des intérimaires ou encore des
extras par exemple de la restauration et
pour eux et bien la réforme de
l'assurance chômage va avoir un impact
très fort alors au final dans ce cortège
il y avait deux types de profils deux
profils de manifestants il y avait ces
fameux salariés précaires qui demande
pour eux mêmes le retrait de cette
réforme de l'assurance chômage et puis
les intermittents mais aussi les
retraités également les
auto-entrepreneurs qui porte la même
revendication mais par solidarité avec
leur collègue écouter alors actuellement
je suis pas concerné si je perds mes
droits un jour je le saurai comme ce que
je tomberai dans la réforme de
l'assurance chômage qui est en train de
se mettre en place et donc mes
indemnités seront gravement baissé parce
que je serais plus couverts par ce
statut particulier de l'intermittence du
spectacle donc chers aux solidarités par
le fait qu'en fait il n'y a pas d'
écoute de la part du gouvernement qui
est en place
oui en effet on est les intermittents
présent parce qu'on est ce qu'ils sont
les plus aptes à s'exprimer et on est là
pour soutenir plein d'autres systèmes
qui sont en cause comme l'hôtellerie le
tourisme plein de mouvements qui sont
arrêtés et qu'ils n'ont pas le droit des
aides actuellement et avec la réforme
qui arrive en avoir encore moins cette
réforme
elle devrait améliorer les conditions de
vie et les revenus des chômeuses et des
chômeurs c'est exactement l'inversé
qu'elle fait elle diminue ce que les
chômeuses et les chômeurs vont recevoir
et pire encore elle diminue le nombre de
gens qui vont pouvoir recevoir des
indemnités de chômage c'est donc tout à
fait inacceptable et je vous le disais
ce cortège s'est arrêté ici devant le
conseil d'état et ce n'est pas un hasard
car hier matin sept syndicats dont la
cgt la cfdt ou encore force ouvrière y
ont déposé un recours en référé
il espère la suspension et même
l'annulation par la plus haute
juridiction administrative de cette
réforme de l'assurance-chômage
mobilisation contre cette réforme dans
d'autres villes de france notamment à
marseille pour les manifestants le
nouveau mode de calcul de
l'indemnisation on va pénaliser les plus
précaires cette réforme doit entrer en
vigueur le 1er juillet elle avait déjà
été retouchée par le gouvernement après
le conseil d'état a mis en évidence une
différence de traitement disproportionné
entre les demandeurs d'emploi malgré des
corrections le texte reste pour tester
est considérée comme une attaque au
droit à l'indemnisation chômage
cette réforme elle est catastrophique
elles mêmes meurtrière en fait c'est
déjà ait eu déjà le principe de la
protection sociale c'est à dire que
quand on travaille en fait on cotise
pour le droit à l'indemnisation
donc une fois qu'on est au chômage va en
fait on est indemnisé et là en fait
cette réforme là c'est une énième
attaque parce que c'est pas la première
à thaksin attaqué depuis des années
contre le droit à l'indemnisation
chômage
donc c'est une manière de
de rabaisser le mal le mode d'existence
des des salariés précaires ou des
emplois peu qualifiés de rabaisser ses
salariés à un niveau un niveau de vie
très très faible en lisant les
contraignant à accepter des conditions
d'embauché et de salaires qui vont
sûrement pas s'arranger après un an de
pandémie quand même qui a bien mis les
gens sur le côté pour beaucoup qui sont
ou au chômage partiel donc avec des
revenus moindres parce qu'ils sont
empêchées de travailler
comment est-ce qu'on peut envisager une
pareille réforme au moment où on doit
soutenir toute une population et où les
services publics et la solidarité
interprofessionnelle doit jouer dans
l'actualité également le pass sanitaire
validé par les 27 membres de l'union
européenne cette semaine sous forme
numérique il permettra de montrer si
vous êtes vacciné contre le kobe 19 ou
alors si vous avez eu un résultat
négatif à votre test il sera demandée
dès le 9 juin en france pour participer
aux événements de plus de 1000 personnes
et puis dès la mi joueurs pour passer
les frontières entre états membres de
lieu à paris une mobilisation a eu lieu
contre ce pass sanitaire le point avec
notre reporter jonathan mois dab au
trocadéro plusieurs centaines de
personnes mobilisées aujourd'hui place
du trocadéro pour manifester contre la
mise en place du pass sanitaires lors de
quoi parle-t-on tout d'abord au niveau
européen c'est le certificat sanitaire
européen qui permettra aux citoyens de
voyager plus librement entre les 27 pays
de l'union
ça permettra de savoir si les individus
sont fatigués
ou de doser quel vaccin savoir s'ils ont
été testés car un pcr on était sans
juger ni ou alors eh bien s'ils ont été
contaminés par le commis de savoir s'ils
ont encore des anticorps c'est pas sur
la mise en place à partir du 1er juillet
en france sera à partir du 9 juin que se
passera mise en place il sera nécessaire
pour et bien assister à des événements
regroupant plus de 1000 personnes dans
lesquelles les gestes barrière ne
peuvent pas être respectées on pense par
exemple à des festivals de musique ou
encore des pièces de théâtre et de
nombreuses personnes ici était contre
l'instauration de ces pass sanitaire je
vous propose de les écouter pour le pass
à lithaire moi je considère que c'est
une contrainte supplémentaire et c'est
vraiment une restriction de liberté
supplémentaire on dit dans les grandes
manifestations on va pouvoir y aller que
si on est vaccinés au d'abord ça va être
très compliqué à contrôler parce que qui
va contrôler que vous avez le bon le bon
certificat qui va contrôler votre
identité
donc c'est déjà très compliquée et
ensuite je vois pas pourquoi à partir
demain ou les personnes à risque sont
vaccinés protéger l'outil se voit pas
pourquoi les autres ne pourraient pas se
rendre à ces manifestations
à lévis le bassin iter sur français
européen c'est le mène de toute façon
j'ai dit c'est big tech et big pharma
qui se donnent la main et sacré big
brother parce que c'est vraiment la
synthèse de tout ce qui nous affecte
c'est à dire à la fois la médecine qui
est très loin de l'acte médical
on est dans l'espèce de
deux spectacles médical effrayant on va
discriminer des gens en fonction de leur
état sérologique fonction leur choix de
vaccination c'est une première c'est une
discrimination
c'est un apartheid sanitaires et sa pr
en dehors de ces personnalités d'autres
personnes ont émis des réserves
concernant ce pas sanitaire c'est
notamment le cas de clerc et dont la
défenseur des droits qui s'est elle
inquiétée et bien de la gestion des
données sanitaires des français de leur
confidentialité
mais aussi je cite du risque de
discrimination que ce pass sanitaire
pourrait faire peser sur le public à
l'entrée des lieux concernés par
l'implantation de se passer d'état le
passé à uniterre ne bénéficiera pas aux
discothèques qui restent toujours
fermées jusqu'à nouvel ordre
hier le conseil d'état a rejeté les
demandes d'exploitante ces
établissements il réclamer leur
réouverture d'ici au 30 juin mais les
juges ont estimé que leur fermeture
n'était pas disproportionnée au regard
de la situation sanitaire
les exploitants s'estiment victimes de
discrimination il espérait être intégré
en urgence au plan de déconfinement du
gouvernement je vous rappelle que les
discothèques sont fermés depuis le 14
mars 2020 et pour morgane dalle
propriétaire d'une discothèque à béthune
cette décision sera lourde de
conséquences et notamment du point de
vue des emplois cet été ne comprend pas
il y aura trois fait même qu'ils vont se
passer c'est à dire qu'il y aura un an
sauvagement de nos centres villes
il aurait également une risque de
quatrième vague sait très bien que nos
jeunes ne seront pas encadré et une fois
de plus on assistera à une nouvelle
délocalisation qui sera la
délocalisation du secteur de la nuit de
la culture nuit vers nos pays voisins ou
non c'est à dire la grèce c'est
l'angleterre
donc nous sommes très inquiet parce que
on observe que tous nos voisins sont en
train de rouvrir leur discothèque il
faut pas oublier que le secteur de la
vie nocturne c'est à peu près 45 mille
emplois
c'est plus d'un milliard de chiffre
d'affaires et alors à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui nous ne sommes pas nous ne
sommes pas en mesure ne pourront pas se
payer ce luxe de faire une croix sur un
milliard de chiffre d'affaires
les conséquences de la crise sanitaire
sont multiples
les municipalités françaises n'échappent
pas à cette réalité respecter le budget
a été quasi impossible en manque de
trésorerie certaines communes ont donc
augmenté les impôts locaux c'est le cas
notamment pour la ville de
dammartin-en-goële en seine et marne
reportage de renault parquet et grégoire
douce et la commune de
dammartin-en-goële fait face à un
casse-tête budgétaire face à l'arrivée
de nouveaux habitants mêlée à la crise
sanitaire difficile de rentrer dans les
clous du budget communal
d'autant que la mairie a dû procéder à
des aménagements au niveau de ses
infrastructures jugée de moins en moins
adaptées aux enjeux auxquels fait face
la municipalité comme plus d'une commune
sur trois selon une étude de
l'association des maires de france et de
la banque des territoires la ville
envisage une hausse de la fiscalité plus
100 % sur la taxe foncière notamment
contre 2 à 3% en moyenne sur le
territoire national selon cette même
enquête
la pilule a du mal à passer par exemple
pour moi qui payais 960 euros
je vais passer à 1553
c'est à dire je vais avoir une
augmentation de 600 euros
on aime bien qu'il y ait un audit qui
soit réalisé des finances de la commune
parce que durant toute la campagne
l'équipe en place a dit que les finances
étaient saines
les finances sont saines et on n'est pas
obligé d'augmenter les impôts dans de
telles proportions
face à la colère des habitants la
municipalité a revu sa copie en baissant
de 25 points le projet de hausse de la
taxe foncière
insuffisant selon les trois collectifs
de da martinois constitué pour
l'occasion qui multiplie les
manifestations mais pour la mairie en
place les investissements prévus sont
nécessaires construction d'un nouveau
gymnase pour remplacer l'ancien qui ne
respectent plus les normes
assainissement d'une école primaire et
agrandissement de deux autres
établissements scolaires en vue de
réduire le nombre d'élèves par classe
bien évidemment la crise sanitaire a
fortement
impacté la commune depuis mars de
l'année dernière il a fallu mettre en
place des dispositifs sanitaires qui
nous ont été imposés dans les écoles et
tous ces dispositifs liés en même temps
à des absences de personnel pour les
raisons qu'on connaît
la commune a dû subvenir au financement
de tous ces agents supplémentaires tout
en maintenant salaires de ceux qui
étaient absents
globalement c'est entre un cinquième et
un quart de dépenses supplémentaires par
rapport à l'habituel dans l'optique de
trouver un terrain d'entente le maire
divers droite assure qu'une nouvelle
proposition sera faite dans le courant
du mois de juin
en attendant un nouveau rassemblement
est prévu ce samedi le point sur le
colis de 19 dans le monde le virus a tué
3 4 millions de personnes un chiffre qui
serait en réalité deux à trois fois plus
élevé selon l'organisation mondiale de
la santé
parmi les régions les plus durement en
deuil et je vous le disais en titre
l'amérique latine les caraïbes qui
comptabilise plus d'un million de décès
c'est l'une des rares zones où les
chiffres repartent à la hausse les
inégalités sur place explique en partie
cette hausse des cas selon sergio
coronado ancien député des français de
l'étranger de la circonscription
amérique latine et conseiller en
communication cette flambée n'est pas
n'est pas une surprise à vrai dire on
sait depuis le début de set quand des
mii donc un virus respiratoires mais
c'est aussi une pandémie de la pauvreté
que ce continent qui connaît des
inégalités de revenus de fortune des
inégalités extrêmement bill violente
n'était pas armé pour faire front à ces
pandémies des systèmes de son et délabré
des hôpitaux très vite saturé à manque
de matériel et puis aujourd'hui la
question de la vaccination
il n'y a pas de vaccin aujourd'hui de
vaccination de masse hormis le chili cas
vacciner 50 % de sa population
donc il reste il reste ce virus qui
continuent à circuler avec des
situations extrêmement critique
déconfinement qui ne peuvent pas
réellement efficace puisque une grande
partie de la population sur le continent
latino-américain vide emplois informels
ce sont des personnes qui si elles ne
sortent pas dans la rue pour gagner de
quoi manger de quoi vivre elles
connaissent d'autres situations de
détresse et d'urgence la situation
sanitaire se dégrade également au népal
le pays subit une seconde vague de
corona virus très virulent ce face au
manque de moyens médicaux
katmandou compte sur l'aide
internationale
les détails avec solène gaudin des
patients soignés sur le parvis de
l'hôpital
placé sous oxygène à même le sol à
katmandou la situation sanitaire semble
hors de contrôle et les malades
désemparés ils m'ont dit que le niveau
d'oxygène était faible et m'ont demandé
de trouver un lit ailleurs parce que
l'hôpital était bondée j'ai essayé
plusieurs endroits et j'en ai trouvé un
dans les locaux de cet hôpital
ainslie était libre lorsque nous sommes
arrivés ici nous avons eu de la chance
de l'avoir voisin de l'inde le népal
connaît une forte recrudescence de cas
de covile 19 avec plus de 8000 nouvelles
contaminations par jour depuis une
semaine
un chiffre qui serait sous-estimer à
cause du manque de tests notamment dans
les régions les plus reculées
à cela s'ajoute l'insuffisance de
matériel médical bouteilles d'oxygène
lee ambulance la transmission pourrait
être moindre dans les zones urbaines
dans les semaines à venir mais elle a
atteint les villages ce qui est
préoccupant
nous leur demandons de vérifier les
niveaux d'oxygène de prescrire des
médicaments et de faire des
radiographies
mais ce n'est pas possible là bas les
personnes avec lesquelles je suis en
contact me le dise autre pénurie celle
des vaccins
le gel le mois dernier des exportations
de ces roms par l'inde gravement touchée
elle aussi par la pandémie empêche plus
d'un million et demi de népalais de
recevoir leur deuxième injection proche
de la rupture de stock
le pays a pu toutefois compter sur
l'aide de la chine qui lui a fourni 800
mille doses de son vaccin sinopharm et
400 bouteilles d'oxygène
ce vendredi la suisse a envoyé à
katmandou 30 tonnes de matériel dont des
tests antigénique malgré l'aide
internationale le nombre de décès a
dépassé les 6000 cas ces derniers jours
dans la capitale katmandou les bûcher
funéraire brûle 8 et jours
les autorités craignent maintenant que
l'épidémie ne se répande comme une
traînée de poudre dans le pays malien
direction le japon où les autorités
tentent de rattraper leur retard dans la
vaccination hier tokyo approuvé
l'utilisation des vaccins de moderna et
d'astrazeneca aujourd'hui 5 millions 500
mille japonais ont reçu une dose de
vaccin à deux mois du lancement des jeux
olympiques alors pour certains ce n'est
pas suffisant quand un voeckler par
dizaines ces japonais font la queue pour
se faire vacciner
tokyo a organisé ce vendredi un exercice
dans un centre de vaccination de masse à
partir de lundi jusqu'à dix mille
personnes par jour pourront recevoir une
dot c'est romantique au vide
tout d'abord nous ils ont donné la
priorité à un programme de vaccination
sûr et sécurisé ensuite nous pouvons
mieux pencher sur l'efficacité
le nombre de personnes vaccinées etc
c'est notre première grande mission
chaque jour nous coopérons et cherchons
à nous améliorer nous effectuerons les
vaccinations dans un souci de sécurité
à ce jour seuls 4% des japonais ont reçu
au moins une dose de vaccin un taux
parmi les plus faibles du monde
mais le japon compte bien mettre les
bouchées doubles pour rattraper son
retard
ce vendredi des autorités ou autoriser
les sérums de moderna et d'astrazeneca
jusqu'à maintenant seul celui de files
or bio wendake et est homologué les
vaccins de modern astrazeneca ont été
officiellement approuvée aujourd'hui à
13 heures c'est viennent d'être annoncés
par le ministère de la santé du travail
et de la protection sociale
nintendo possible le vaccin de moderna
sera utilisée et la quantité de vaccin
utilisable augmentera nous souhaitons
donc accéléré l'inoculation les masses
contrairement aux vaccins de modern à
celui d'astrazeneca pourrait ne pas être
distribué tout de suite les autorités
japonaises se montrant très prudente en
raison des rares cas de thrombose qui
lui sont liés pour autant le
gouvernement japonais est engagé dans
une course contre la montre
une nouvelle vague épidémique touche le
pays et l'état d'urgence sanitaire a été
élargie à 10 préfecture jusqu'au 20 juin
et si les japonais semblent désormais
opposés à la tenue des jeux olympiques
le comité international olympique la sur
ces jo de tokyo auront bien lieu cet été
mais la vie que nous avons de l'eau et
metz et de tous les autres avis
scientifiques et médicaux sont que
toutes les mesures que nous avons
décrits dans les livres de jeux et
l'itération actuelle de ce si toutes ces
mesures que nous entreprenons sont
satisfaisantes et assureront des jeux
sûr et sécurisé en termes de santé et
c'est le cas qu'il y ait un état
d'urgence
[Musique]
à moins de neuf semaines du début des
jeux olympiques
la vaccination apparaît comme le dernier
rempart contre une reprise épidémique au
total 2
100 millions de doses ont été commandées
à pfizer bintec 50 millions à modern art
et 120 millions astrazeneca
le gouvernement japonais s'est fixé pour
objectif de vacciner l'ensemble des plus
de 65 ans d'ici la fin juillet en
turquie alors que la campagne de
vaccination a débuté il ya plus de 4 au
mois certains habitants des zones
rurales ne sont pas convaincus par la
vaccination
le gouvernement turc a donc dépêché des
équipes médicales chargées de leur
expliquer l'importance de se faire
vacciner à maya souple et des équipes
pour persuader les habitants de
certaines villes rurales en turquie la
raison de leur présence
nombre de rejette les vaccins anti
qu'ovide à mardin commune située au sud
du pays
des unités mobiles tentent de convaincre
les plus réticents
effrayé à l'idée de recevoir le sérum
certains acceptaient finalement de se
faire vacciner par les équipes médicales
parfois sur le bord de la route
j'avais peur de tomber malade et d'être
paralysé mais les équipes médicales
m'ont dit que c'était pour mon bien
je les ai cru et je me suis fait
vacciner les gens me disaient de ne pas
me faire vacciner
mais monfils et l'équipe médicale on
insistait pour que je me fasse vacciner
parce que ce serait bon pour moi je leur
ai fait confiance et je me suis fait
vacciner
que dieu bénisse tous ceux qui ont joué
un rôle dans cette affaire
depuis le mois d'avril les bureaux de
santé locaux sont en charge d'appeler
les populations éligibles à la
vaccination et de les rassurer quant à
ses bénéfices parallèlement à cette
campagne d'appels les travailleurs de
santé se déplacent munis de glacière
remplie de vaccins parfois accompagné de
dirigeants communautaires
une initiative qui rassure la population
selon le directeur provincial de la
santé à mardin 8000 personnes ont déjà
été vaccinées par les équipes
spécialisées selon certains médecins une
conversation directe sur le terrain
permettrait beaucoup plus facilement de
faire changer d'avis les plus hésitants
en turquie seulement 14% de la
population a entièrement été vaccinées
le ministre turc de la santé se montre
néanmoins optimiste
d'après lui le pays pourrait atteindre
l'immunité collective avant le mois
d'août grâce à la campagne de
vaccination menée par le gouvernement
autres titres de l'actualité la
mobilisation parisienne en soutien au
peuple palestinien à paris cette fois
donc elle a été autorisée mais assez
avec l'obligation de rester sur la place
de la république
une mobilisation qui arrive après les
affrontements sanglants de ces derniers
jours entre le hamas et l'armée
israélienne
dès 18 heures les manifestants ont été
dispersés par les forces de l'ordre le
point avec notre reporter sur place le
qualifie les manifestants ont quitté
sans heurts la place de la république
après plusieurs heures de manifestation
au plus haut niveau de ce rassemblement
sk plusieurs milliers de personnes ici
pour afficher leur solidarité avec la
palestine et dénoncé les tirs de tsahal
sur la bande de gaza qui engendrait de
nombreuses victimes ces manifestants
considèrent que le cessez-le-feu entre
israël et le hamas ne résout pas les
problèmes de fond du conflit notamment
la colonisation je vous propose
d'écouter quelques manifestants que j'ai
pu interroger au début de cette
manifestation
ben il ya un cessez-le-feu et c'est très
bien nous sommes preneurs
maintenant il faut que l'apartheid cesse
parce que l'apartheid en israël continue
l'occupation continue la colonisation
continue et nous voulons que tout ceci
c'est ce qu'ils nient pas de temps en
temps comme ça épisodiquement et puis où
est même régulièrement d une répression
féroce qui s'abat sur le peuple
palestinien que ça soit en cisjordanie à
jérusalem à gaza ou même dose chez les
palestiniens d'israël
le peuple palestien iil est il est en
grand danger et il faut que le
retournement de la société civile
ils interviennent vite et fort notamment
à travers le développement de la
campagne de sanctions contre israël de
boycott désinvestissement sanctions la
campagne bds de manière à ce que israël
sache que l'occupation et la répression
ben c'est pas gratuit ce à un coût
plusieurs personnalités sont venues
apporter leur soutien aux manifestants
notamment le secrétaire général de la
cgt philippe martinez qui a pris la
parole ici devant la foule ou encore le
député et les filles eric coquerel que
je vous propose d'écouter tout de suite
il avait dans le monde aujourd'hui un
peuple colonisé un peuple qui est
exproprié de sa terre de sa capitale
équipes sont normales pour un député
france a soumises et du côté justement
des gens qui sont là victimes de ce
conflit
la deuxième chose c'est que plus que
jamais il est nécessaire d'exprimer sa
solidarité avec la cause palestinienne
de demander l'application des
résolutions de l'onu
c'est à dire le fait que la palestine
est un mieux de véritables
autodétermination un véritable état avec
jérusalem pour capitale partagée parce
que c'est la seule chance de paix et que
toute autre solution n'est pas bonne
pour les palestiniens bien sûr mais à
terme à l'est pas non plus bonne pour
les israéliens
ces manifestants reprochent aussi à
l'état français de ne pas assez
s'impliquer dans la défense du peuple
palestinien notamment la dénonciation
des violences commises
par israël il reproche aussi aux
autorités d'avoir interdit la
manifestation de la semaine précédente
qui s'était soldée par 45 garde à vue
après des heures en tout cas cette
manifestation ci s'est terminée dans le
calme
voilà pour cette édition merci vous de
l'avoir suivi prochain point sur
l'actualité dans une trentaine de
minutes
à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
en avril aura lieu le 60e anniversaire
du vol de youri gagarine en ayant eu la
chance de m'entraîner avec nos collègues
russes
j'ai vraiment plongé dans une atmosphère
où j'ai vécu auprès de nero et gagarine
était présent à chaque point de
bâtiments de salles de sport de place de
la cité des étoiles moi je crois
beaucoup dans le